I want to bring something up that I'm
not happy about national boss day was
last week that's a real thing national
boss day happened last week and I'm
bringing this up because my entire staff
forgot not kidding I'm serious they
completely forgot I feel like I do a lot
for everybody here no one said a word to
me not even a thank you
uh no we we didn't forget oh come on
Andy it's too late now to pretend that
you remembered you did no no no we
forgot on purpose
so that it would be a surprise so happy
national boss they known and no no no
one's buying this and I don't believe
you I just don't believe that you know I
don't believe it no we did we
we made you a song we wrote a song for
you you wrote it wait a minute you wrote
a song get over here come on come on
what do you tell you yeah come on guys
let's sing that song we wrote for Conan
okay just like we rehearsed okay here we
go a one and A two Anna
[Applause]
Brady's
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
no no that's not a dance the whole staff
chipped in he gave you a cash gift come
on give me some money to mr. money what
do you got coins doesn't have enough
[ __ ] man
here you go this is just oh this is lame
and it's clear you know it's just clear
you just forgot you forgot it's okay
just say you forgot no I mean if we
forgot and then how would we have gotten
the whole audience involved right
five six seven eight sing with us
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute that was incredible
what a lovely song that you all sang
together
Wow I'm touched and I apologize we have
a great show story the new Netflix
series living with yourself Paul ride is
on the program
everybody